new here at 11 o'clock an elderly man
shot and killed in front of his home
after two people followed him home
sunday night now it happened on bennett
drive not too far from tropicana and
mountain vista
tonight police have arrested two people
believed to be
responsible 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough has been following this case
since last night
and she spoke with the man's family and
neighbors tonight madison
yes the victim's name is alan bondilid
and he died just steps away from his
home
that you see behind me lit up behind me
that was
actually the neighbors who called 911
explaining that something was going on
after they heard gunshots
late sunday afternoon i just sat down to
watch tv and i heard a shot
i looked down my front window and saw a
couple of cars out here and a bunch of
people
tim santro describing the final moments
of his neighbor's life
seventy-year-old alan bondilid was shot
beaten
and left for dead right outside of his
home the suspect's 36 year old otis
buchanan and 31 year old
delana smedley allegedly followed him
from a bar
to his house a home the victim always
enjoyed decorating
he would always go out because as you
can see all the lights so for halloween
christmas stuff like that he would
always go out of his way
to do this decoration and he'd be out
there all day putting this stuff up and
made it quite extensive santoro says
bondolid was always very active around
his home
he just seemed like a very motivated
like to keep busy like to have his hands
and stuff he has lots of tools he has
all that stuff he's always out here
doing something
although his family didn't want to go on
camera they said they turned the lights
on tonight in his memory
yeah those lights you can see behind me
are well
lit now the suspects are facing murder
charges and numerous amounts
open murder and robbery with a deadly
weapon along with conspiracy to commit
robbery with a deadly weapon
their first court appearance is going to
be tomorrow reporting live madison
kimbrough
8 news now